hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and today i will
be talking about the new massive
development in the seven deadly sins
sequel manga lancelot the son of bonn
and elaine has finally appeared in the
series although you could say that he's
been there all along and not only is
lancelot here but he is also an absolute
ruthless badass who takes no prisoners
and i love him already this is huge for
the seven deadly sins sequel so let's
get into it if you guys enjoy our seven
deadly sins and four nights of the
apocalypse content and you want us to
keep it going leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
really helps with that youtube algorithm
and if you're new to the channel or you
watch our videos but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
quick favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications
subscribing is a totally free method of
directly supporting this channel in a
very real way finally it should go
without saying that this video will
contain spoilers for the four nights of
the apocalypse manga so please proceed
with caution you have been warned okay
so if you've been following my four
nights of the apocalypse coverage here
on the channel then you know that i've
been saying since the beginning that sin
must be either bon or lancelot in
disguise that is because having a fox
named sin who also happens to know
members of the seven deadly sins like
gother and a bunch of other extremely
useful information would be far too much
of a coincidence if there wasn't a
direct connection to either bonn or
lancelot well in the most recent
chapters since true identity was finally
revealed at this point in the story
percival donnie nacienne's ann and sin
are engaged in combat with the dark
talismans an order of five holy nights
from camelot who tried to kill our
heroes inside the entangled forest
percival and the gang were doing quite
well thanks to sin's excellent strategic
advice but in the end the dark talismans
managed to corner our heroes and it
looked like the fight was over percival
managed to prolong the fight a bit
thanks to the power of hope that his
friends have placed in him but that is
when the four remaining dark talismans
surround the sin the fox the talismans
have determined that sin is the
commander of the group he is the reason
why they are still alive since he has
been guiding them every step of the way
so the talismans have decided to take
sin down first if they eliminate the
brains of the group then percival and
the others will quickly collapse
according to the talismans sin knows way
too much about them and they can sense
that he has a connection to the king of
leonis himself so the talisman isolates
sin from the others using perfect cube
and then they attempt to kill him before
moving on to killing percival and the
others to be perfectly clear the
talismans are not trying to capture our
heroes or scare them away they are
straight up trying to kill them sin
proclaims that if the talismans are
ready to kill others then they must be
ready to be killed themselves he then
reveals his true identity lancelot the
son of bonn and elaine and he then
proceeds to kill all the talismans
except for fidash fidech is shocked that
he's never heard the name lancelot
despite lancelot being such an
incredibly strong holy knight surely he
would have heard rumors about such a
legendary warrior but lancelot the
absolute chadly badass simply explains
that rumors are spread by survivors and
he leaves no survivors if anyone tries
to kill him he kills them first and so
no one is left to spread any rumors
because dead men tell no tales whoa this
man is so badass freaking lancelot
jaeger over here we then learned that
lancelot uses a bow and arrow with
amazing speed and accuracy that he is
left-handed and that he possesses
transformation magic it is this magic
that allows him to turn into a fox and
of course when he turns himself into a
fox he becomes a much smaller target for
his opponents on top of that he has
incredible offensive capabilities both
with his arrows and with his bare hands
he is able to kill one of the talismans
on the spot with just a punch to the
abdomen for his part finish has a magic
called haste that gives him unbelievable
speed and in fact he can move so quickly
that purcell and the others can't even
follow his movements fidech tries to use
this speed to attack lancelot but
lancelot is able to dodge without even
breaking a sweat in fact lancelot
welcomes this battle as a nice little
warm-up because being a fox for a long
time makes him feel like his fighting
skills are out of practice no matter
what footage does and no matter how hard
he does it lancelot is able to
anticipate what he is doing and he
dodges and counters it before footage
can do anything it's almost as if
lancelot can anticipate viticus
movements before he even makes them but
more on that later lancelot then asks
fidech whether he knows a knight who has
a helmet with a star-shaped visor fidech
doesn't give a clear answer he just says
that he doesn't know what lancelot means
but even from that non-answer lancelot
is able to determine that fidech knows
the knight lancelot then asks a second
question does fittich know where dubs
the master craftsman of the giant clan
is this is of course the same dubs from
the cursed by light movie which gives
yet more credence to my argument that
the movie is canon once again even
though footage doesn't really answer
lancelot can tell that he doesn't know
where dubs is at this point finish
realizes that lancelot can somehow read
his mind which is why he was able to
anticipate all his movements before he
even made them so fidech just gives up
on the fight entirely and he attempts to
use his amazing speed to run away he
wants to get back to camelot and report
this monster called lancelot to king
arthur and the others fidech intends to
make lancelot one of the most wanted men
in britannia along with all the knights
of the apocalypse but lancelot just
calmly takes donny's dagger and uses a
spell called the shining road to turn
the dagger into some sort of homing
missile the dagger zooms through a
pathway of light until it catches up to
finish and destroys both him and his
horse in a matter of seconds damn
poor horse
as percival and the others look on in
shock our boy lancelot yeager simply
restates his previous statement anyone
who chooses to fight him will not live
to tell the tale back in camelot king
arthur learns that the dark talismans
have been destroyed as soon as it
happens because a talisman that he had
in his possession crumbles to pieces
when they die arthur casually says that
oh boy that was fast so maybe he should
take these so-called knights of the
apocalypse more seriously he asks merlin
if he should prioritize taking out the
four knights over finding a bride but
merlin just tells him to follow his own
wishes
bro who hurt this man not only did he go
and become a villain but he's out here
talking about finding a bride when he is
merlin right there arthur has completely
lost his damn mind and honestly i'm
getting more and more curious about what
happened to make arthur change so much
during the time skip between the
original series and the sequel the more
we learn about him and merlin the more
fascinating this question becomes
back in the entangled forest percival
and the gang are struggling to come to
terms with what an incredible badass
lancelot is and is shocked that he is
able to just kill the talismans without
batting an eye percival is crying and
thanking lancelot for saving them donnie
is upset that his dagger was broken and
nacienda is just like chilling i guess
when anne asks lancelot why he was going
around pretending to be a fox lancelot
explains that he is a servant of the
king of leonis and his mission is to
track down a potential member of the
four knights of the apocalypse and bring
him and his companions to leonis that is
exactly what he has been doing with
percival and the others his job was to
guide them to leonis while interfering
as little as possible i'm guessing that
this journey of theirs was also a sort
of test lancelot was observing percy in
order to determine whether he really was
one of the prophesized knights of the
apocalypse so because this was a type of
test he didn't want to just take them
all straight to leonis he wanted percy
to get stronger and prove himself during
the journey itself lancelot disguised
himself as a fox because he didn't want
the holy knights of camelot to discover
who he was and what he was doing but
lancelot was also the one looking out
for percy and the gang the whole time
like when he defeated all those demons
back in sistana and then said that his
friends did it
so it seems that lancelot serves as a
sort of secret agent for the king of
leonis and transformation magic is
basically the perfect magic for a secret
agent so lancelot is very good at his
job he carries out important secret
missions and he keeps such a low profile
that no one has ever heard of him before
and if they engage with him in battle
they don't live to tell about it and
unless something has changed in the last
few years we know that the king of
leonis is none other than meliodas so
that means that lancelot works directly
for meliodas himself this is extremely
cool because it means that we might
actually see meliodas in the story very
soon and i've been hoping for a long
time that the main characters from the
original story would start playing a
bigger role in the sequel so all of this
is a great sign as lancelot proceeds to
bury the dark talismans percy asks him
about the two people whom lancelot had
inquired about the knight with the
star-shaped visor and that craftsman
lancelot simply replies that those
questions were related to his personal
business and they were not part of the
mission after lancelot buries the
talismans he plants a seed at each grave
stating that even though they are dead
they can continue to exist as life in
this forest so although lancelot might
appear to be ruthless for outright
slaying all of his enemies he does have
a conscience and he does give his
enemies a proper burial and when we
consider the fact that lancelot only
kills in self-defense after his enemies
tried to kill him first it's clear that
lancelot is only ruthless when he has to
be now the fact that lancelot can both
read people's minds and transform his
shape makes nacience think that he may
be from the fairy clan and we of course
know that he is half human and half
fairy but before lancelot can even
answer percy interrupts him with
thoughts about poop meanwhile our old
friend pellegard shows up and says that
he wants to hang out with percy and the
gang as you will recall pelligard is the
holy night of camelot who wanted to make
percival his apprentice and we met him
in the first few chapters of the story
but before peligar can try to convince
percy to become his apprentice lancelot
just transports them all right into the
kingdom of leonis leaving pelligard by
himself in the forest as percy and the
gang stare in amazement at the castle of
leonis lancelot tells them that the king
is waiting for them and that is how
chapter 50 of the four nights of the
apocalypse ends
bro are we about to see meliodas
elizabeth and maybe even tristan in the
sequel for the very first time this is
honestly awesome i loved lancelot's
intro he seems to be like such a cool
character already and it looks like he
is about to introduce percy and the gang
to meliodas this means that we are about
to get some crucial information about
what really happened during the time
skip and it also seems like the main
characters from the original could start
playing a much bigger role in the sequel
which is awesome personally i've been
really enjoying the four nights of the
apocalypse so far even though like every
new manga it had some slower arcs that
served as an introduction to the new
main characters and that is to be
expected but now with 50 chapters behind
us and everything that just happened
surrounding this lancelot reveal i am
extremely excited to see where this
story is going to go from here i have
never been more excited about reading
the next chapter of the four nights of
the apocalypse than i have been in the
last few weeks and i can't wait to see
what happens next let me know down in
the comments if you agree that the story
has become just so much better with the
appearance of lancelot and speaking of
lancelot what was all of that about his
personal business that night with the
star-shaped visor that he mentions was
actually shown very briefly back in
chapter 6. in that chapter he looked
like just some random npc but i guess
he's actually important to the story why
do you guys think that lancelot is
looking for this night in particular
could he also be someone we already know
in disguise comment down below who you
think the knight with the star-shaped
visor is and speaking of chapter 6 that
is the same chapter in which we got
those brief descriptions of the four
nights of the apocalypse based on some
prophecies that the knights of camelot
have access to one of the knights was
described as a child with verdant
wing-like hair and that child is of
course percival another is described as
a mysterious lad with no fixed
appearance and that description seems to
fit lancelot perfectly we also have a
boy with holiness and evil in his eyes a
description which matches tristan who is
the son of a goddess and a demon and
finally we have a boy bearing gold
colored magic and that is the only
member of the four knights whose
identity we still don't know i think it
could be the child of king and diane but
that's just speculation definitely drop
a comment with your thoughts on who the
fourth night of the apocalypse is going
to be also why is lancelot looking for
dubs is dubs the one who will give
lancelot that lance that we see in
chapter 5 the lance that belongs to the
knight of war out of the four nights of
the apocalypse the knight of war is the
one whose hairstyle matches lancelot so
it's likely that the knight of war is
supposed to be an older lancelot the
night of death is of course an older
percival the knight of pestilence looks
like an older tristan and the night of
famine is the fourth night of the
apocalypse finally i really want to know
what happened to lancelot and jericho
between the time that they disappeared
and now was lancelot abducted by the
lady of the lake and if so what happened
then how did he free himself and of
course how did he start working for the
king of leonis and last but not least
where is my underrated waifu queen
jericho seriously though so far
lancelot's reveal was simply amazing i
love him as a character i love his many
awesome magical abilities including of
course reading minds shape-shifting
those arrows shining road it's just so
cool i am super excited to learn more
about what happened to lancelot during
the time skip and i can't wait to see
what happens next if you guys enjoyed
this video and you want to see more in
the future just leave a quick like it
only takes a second but it helps a lot
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to anime uproar if you haven't already
you might think it doesn't matter but
subscribing actually helps me out a lot
on youtube you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar i
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to kyle salisbury this man is
an absolute mad lad and a disciple of
lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
alpha sigma ingrata algital pate heffa
the red haired fox hinokami and water
the toasted chi corey mcgowan spider
left tanel tungsten tarkis big buddhist
and jeremy cummings finally thank you
also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews alicia octor bonnie
parks joy and garcia fat boy games kaido
might be a duck jessica rabbit jeremy
phillips and alivania if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patreon exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you